hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is sums up the channel about how to
survive in the online jungle now today
i'm going to talk to you about how
criminals gain access to sensitive
information by attacking the weakest
link in the system
[Music]
you and i'm going to specific examples
of popular methods so that you don't
fall for these tricks later fraud can
only be counted by the power of
knowledge so let's see if you'd swallow
the bait
now we begin to master the methods of
social engineering at a very early age
the ability to get what you want not by
force or threats but with simple words
now this actually starts to develop when
you play with children in your local
neighborhood everyone develops a
manipulative skill set in a different
way and that's why some children might
grow up to be dorted or salesmen
advertising agents or even politicians
and the most gifted ones well they
become hackers hackers of people people
are often the weakest link in the system
of security measures and it is they who
constantly calls the latter to become
rather ineffective these are the famous
words of bruce schneiner a renowned
computer security expert now at the turn
of the century the american programmer
and a mathematician wrote a book that
became a handy book on both sides of the
fence and it was used by both hackers
and cyber security specialists now it's
really hard to argue with schneider here
for instance do you see this computer
now i can try and talk to my mac as long
as i like to try and convince it to give
me the password i can say all i want to
do is print one page of a word document
or check my email but really no matter
how many words i save to my computer it
will not let me in i mean yes i could
disassemble it and connect to the hard
drive separately i could try to decrypt
the contents of the files but i
certainly can't persuade it if you want
to hack a computer you need tools you
want to hack a person well simple words
are enough we're talking about cyber
security today and how safe people's
passwords are what is one of your online
passwords currently it is my dog's name
and the year i graduated from high
school what kind of dog do you have i
have a child with papillon and what's
his name jamison jameson
everything i'm about to tell you is not
a guide to action ladies and gentlemen
i'm certainly not encouraging you to
find out the information they're not
supposed to i just simply want you to be
aware of the danger so that you don't
fall prey to scammers if you find
yourself in a similar situation
so
let's start with telemarketing
but there's more if for any reason you
don't want to keep it just return it
back to us and do get your money back
now this energetic man you just saw was
actually mistaken for an actor and his
child but he wasn't one ron papel
actually created the shop at home format
itself and to do so he had to penetrate
the minds of all middle class american
citizens it's just four easy payments of
just 39.90
so in his teens ron made his living by
selling his father's strange invention
universal vegetable chopping knives and
it was at a maxwell street market behind
the counter of an old flea market where
ron actually learned how to sell in the
beginning he was fairly timid and
cautious but then he realizes that the
quicker and the more assertive he talks
the faster he can actually convince
people to buy his wonderful kitchen
utensils
of course different people ask different
questions but if you prompt them with
questions you hint or quickly shift
their attention from one thing to
another like i'm sure you've all
encountered with estate agents people
are very easy to manipulate and just one
scripted conversation really works
wonders now it was with this very script
that ron appeared on television with in
the early 1950s
and unsurprisingly it was an incredible
success ron actually managed to sell
nearly two billion dollars worth of
goods throughout his lifetime this is an
incredible figure how many people in my
audience here today
would like to are going to order one of
these machines when it goes on
television can i see a show of hands
now here's the thing a pre-prepared
script that precedes questions is often
used by scammers who are trying to trick
you to share your credit card details or
the passwords to one of your accounts
and this is called pre-texting
pretext is the basis of this method the
starting point from which the deception
begins so look if i walk up to in the
street and ask for your facebook
password you'll probably look at me and
say no but on the other hand imagine
that your profile's been hacked and you
want to
call the help desk to get your password
recovered
well would you answer the operator's
question as to what your old password
was
most of us would
okay give me your password
my password
out with it you see the attitude to the
question depends on the situation and
also the pretext for the conversation
and it's really unsurprising that
scammers take advantage of this
remember you must never tell your
password from any account to anyone no
customer service professional or banking
administrator will ever ask you to share
this information with them now some
situations can actually be simulated
artificially for instance let's say you
open up your computer and you see that
your social network was hacked right so
you straight away called the support
team and the call was strangely dropped
but then an operator called you back
immediately now this operator will
likely have one objective to get your
password from you during the phone call
now in the age of ip telephony it's not
that difficult to replace a caller's
number on a facebook hotline so right
from the start you'll think you've
received a call from a social networking
company now this is already a good
starting point but we need a very well
written script to get it right so what
does it look like or what does it sound
like if they don't use a script
good time of the day uh bradley we've
noticed that your account is well being
used to send out messenger ads and we'd
like to make sure they're not violating
the terms of the user agreement please
tell us your password and we'll actually
check whether it's you or not
pretty unconvincing right completely the
scammer is too fuzzy with words he's
clearly unsure of himself or herself
right and the pauses actually leave time
to think and conjure up questions so
cheetahs will actually use another
scenario that will really knock you off
balance immediately hello bradley peak
i'm bill gilbert senior manager for
police cooperation facebook now
yesterday at 7 17 p.m a photo archive
was sent from your laptop to your friend
bruce schneiner now these photos fall
under eu directive 7 to combat the
distribution of child pornography this
is a serious criminal offense bradley
now police lieutenant kevin litnick is
with me now he wants to make sure that
you were unaware that the archive was
actually sent so in order for us to
compare the log and the current state of
the profile please provide your password
i sincerely hope this is just an
unfortunate misunderstanding
otherwise you will be spending the next
five years in jail now that kind of
treatment is bound to get a pretty
violent reaction from you notice how the
scammer incoherently talks in facts and
figures i mean it gives you a bunch of
names most of which you don't even
understand
and also he knows when you were online
last afternoon now all of this already
seems to like an interrogation and you
subconsciously want to justify yourself
quickly now in this scenario you are
much more likely to just tell them your
password right you don't want five years
in jail now this is especially effective
if the scammers are able to choose the
right time for instance let's say you're
coming home after a bar crawl now
alcohol can actually impair logical
thinking and it'll probably raise the
chances of you getting caught out
and not only that but the critics will
probably know your friends names and the
time when you were online yesterday this
is just by adding you as a friend on the
very facebook
so remember never post pictures from
bars or big parties until you're sober
the next morning and in any condition
never tell others your password i cannot
stress that enough
[Music]
now this method of pretexting is as old
as phones themselves and no wonder
scammers always try to use new
technologies before ordinary people
catch on to how those new technologies
work by the way the second method of
hacking that i want to tell you about
also appeared in the early days of the
american telephone system and it's now
probably the most popular tactic that's
used among you guessed it online
scammers
now do you know who the inventor of the
automatic telephone exchange was
well the owner of a funeral home is the
correct answer now elman brown stroga
ran his modest business in kansas city
and one day he noticed that the more
telephones that appeared in town the
less often new customers would come to
him stroga decided to investigate this
relationship a little bit and he found
out that his main competitor's wife was
working as a telephone operator so she
would transfer any phone calls related
to funerals to her husband's funeral
home away from stroga's funeral home now
stroke was a pretty resourceful man and
he decided this had to be dealt with
systematically a couple of years later
he created the world's first
automatic telephone exchange now the
revolutionary invention quickly put all
of these telephone operators out of
business
let's take a look at a classic fishing
scheme
attackers force you to end up not at all
where you want it
now a scenario that has played out many
times is effectively an email that looks
like it's coming from your bank now
imagine that an email informs you that
there was a major failure at the bank
system to avoid problems with your
plastic card you are advised to follow
the link in the email
fill out the form
so you click on the link and you're
taken to what appears to be your bank's
website where you log in and fill out
the requested fields your name card
number pin card verification code then
you press the ok button
just like that the attacker is taking
control of your bank account and all
your money is gone the sender's address
was forged and although it looked like a
familiar bank address it was sent from a
completely different server the link in
the letter that you were clicking on
actually directed you to a fake website
and someone registered a domain very
similar to the one who was trying to
impersonate now the differences can
actually be very well thought out and
they can be really minuscule for
instance they might use a large i in
place of a small l
see it's almost impossible to tell the
difference in the address bar sometimes
scammers can actually use another
country's domain extension people often
don't pay attention to that they just
see the name right and copying the
site's design and placing the form at
the desired address is literally a
matter of a few minutes work no wonder
phishing is the most popular form of
social engineering but how do you
protect yourself from these attacks
firstly many popular antivirus programs
and firewalls have anti-phishing modules
do not neglect this get yourself on an
antivirus platform right but secondly i
do not recommend following such links
whatsoever if you have received such an
email from the bank really don't be too
lazy to manually type it in the address
bar and see what it's all about this
will significantly reduce the chance of
ending up on some scam site
and thirdly any incomprehensible
situation with a credit card do not
hesitate to phone the bank's call center
and that's on a number that is always on
the card itself take out your credit
card now and look on the back it will be
there confirm payments online with banks
that have already switched to two factor
authentication systems because even if
scammers trick you into a fake payment
page sending an sms with a confirmation
code to your phone is really a much more
difficult task now if phishing appeared
in america at the end of the 19th
century the next hacking method we're
going to talk about was invented way
back
in 1184 bc
[Music]
i'm sure you've often times heard of the
trojan horse according to legend the
siege of the ancient city of troy lasted
for nine years neither side could
actually gain an advantage the attacking
greeks found the city's walls
impenetrable and the trojans were too
few in numbers to actually overcome the
enemy in the end the siege could have
dragged on forever but the cunning of
the sears came up with a fraudulent
solution the greeks built a huge horse
out of wood and they retreated from troy
leaving this horse behind as a gift for
the gods
celebrating their new victory the
trojans rolled this wooden horse back
into their city
during the night the soldiers hidden
inside the horse snuck out and they
opened the city gates to allow the
entire greek force to swarm in this is
of course a metaphor for the hacking
method that's successfully used nowadays
all over the world only instead of a
wooden horse scammers are using emails
or messages containing various
attachments with viruses or links to
websites with malicious code so we're
now actually going to see if this method
works i'm actually going to send my
friends a simple message right
do you have any idea who posted this
video of me
and then i'm going to add a link
but this link won't lead to youtube or
facebook right for each email i'll
actually create my own notes on the priv
note website now this actually lets you
send private notes that self-destruct as
soon as they're read by the intended
recipient they're mostly used to share
passwords or other confidential
information but for me they'll
effectively serve as a signal if the
note vanishes we'll know that my friend
clicked on the link right
[Music]
now i'm going to disguise the site's
address using something called bitdo url
shortener now you can't really tell
where this link leads as you can imagine
right okay this looks all set now i'm
going to send the links to a dozen of my
acquaintances and in a couple of hours
i'll actually check how many of these
notes have been destroyed and i'll know
how many of my friends have clicked on
my link
[Music]
so i just came back from lunch and it's
an hour and a bit later and this
experiment has already showed two things
first of all why friends spend way too
much time on the internet right and
secondly yes even this simple trick
worked on them
11 notes it self-destructed an hour
later and there was only one person that
i sent this to that didn't read the
message but look how can you protect
yourself against trojan threats well
first of all scan all of the files you
receive with your ansi virus software if
you're using windows please tell me
you've got something
please if not go download mcafee or
kaspersky or something right now right
just google and see virus software
you'll find a million results anyway
secondly you need to pay attention to
their extensions there's the extensions
on the file if you've received an image
with dot exe on the end you should
definitely not open it no matter what
also watch out for shortened links that
look a bit suspicious and don't actually
follow these unless it's really
absolutely necessary if you do end up
clicking on one of these fraudulent
dodgy links by mistake don't trust the
content that they show it is probably
very fraudulent
guys technology is changing very quickly
before we knew it rotary dial phones
were changing to push button ones and
then the first mobile phones appeared
right with their big blocky formats and
they looked and weighed like a few
bricks right then in a matter of years
after that they transformed to these
smartphones that fits in our hand and
were light and you could touch them
right
email subsequently burst into our life
and then the internet that gave way to
social networks and instant messengers
and oh god it seems like i've got master
tick tock as well
so yes technology is still evolving at
that astonishing pace but people
remaining the same they are as easily
fooled as they were back in the days of
elements stroga graham bell or even
odysseus right and scammers are
undoubtedly using it to their advantage
so stay alert don't trust anyone in the
online jungle apart from your guide
bradley i'd like to end with one more
quote by bruce schneiner in terms of
safety the mathematical apparatus is
flawless computers are vulnerable
networks are generally lousy and people
are just discussing that's it for today
i'm bradley this has been some sub take
care see you in the next video
[Music]